we're here with Fareed Zakaria talking
about the Indian election it is exciting
he's a transformative candidate Modi but
and there is a big but and that but took
place in 2002 right it's also the but is
nearly the but is not just about what
happened in 2002 it's that he comes from
a very extreme hardline kind of Hindu
nationalist background something called
the RSS this was the organization one of
whose members are shot Mahatma Gandhi in
1948 so it has a long past of having
been fairly tough on minorities
particularly the Muslim minority in
India 2002 Modi was the head of the
government of Gujarat one of the states
in India there were riots and in those
riots a thousand Muslims died and it was
alleged that he is the head of the the
government either encouraged or ignored
the fact that the police were actually
actively assisting in the kind of
vigilante violence that ended up killing
a thousand people and of course
displacing tens of thousand his actual
role seems to me a little bit less clear
there are investigations that have
cleared him from it the way the best I
can tell of it it's like those
politicians in the South and the United
States during the civil rights movement
where they knew what the police was
going to do if they didn't actively you
know so it's an it's a sin of omission
where he didn't tell the police go out
and and and kill anyone but he knew by
not restraining them bad things might
happen so it's it's a little murky but
it's something he does have to get over
if he is now prime minister of all you
know 1.1 billion Indians right but it's
a sin of omission with a thousand dead
people at the end of it that's the
problem and yet incredibly I was seeing
that there were Muslims in India who
voted for Modi anyway because they
thought he would be stronger on the
economy and at that point is that not
the final example of elections are just
about the economy he could have killed
or been involved in killing your people
you think well you know if the stock
market goes up he is the best for the
job
well it also shows you how frustrated
and aspirational Indians have become
frustrated by the fact that they were
growing at 8% a year and then it dropped
a 5% I know this doesn't sound like in
the United States to say we're only
growing at 5% but India's of course a
very poor country and so to go from 8%
where you thought you were kind of
entering the ranks of the China's of the
world and all of a sudden for that whole
thing to to collapse huge huge problem
and again the Indian media as you showed
is very lively very vigorous at all so
they're constantly showing you you know
this is what you could be living like
this is there's a kind of Bollywood
aspect to Indian news media which is
insane it yeah but it does feed that
kind of aspirational class I'm telling
you they are one sentence away from just
all collectively bursting into song but
it's not just you know there are you
know India has 15 languages only about
15% of India speaks English there are 18
all news channels in English in India 18
we have got like 3 in the United States
you're welcome but this this that Modi
and 2002 poses a problem for America
diplomatically now because he was banned
he had a visa revoked here so he's not
technically allowed into the country
other than on state visits I imagine
well as it turns out technically because
he's Prime Minister he can get what is
it was called an a.1 visa which is a
special category so he's gotta get he's
got to get out of jail free pass pass
well it's fantastic so if you want to
visit if you want to visit Disneyworld
just become Prime Minister and actly
it's all you're exactly but but you're
right for 10 years he couldn't come here
as a private citizen even as the head of
the state government because he was on
this side the list though is very
bizarre right it's a list of one person
it is it has only ever been used to keep
this one person out and and as often
happens with American foreign policy
it's more I kind of a incoherence an
accident that produced it they set up
this commission on religious intolerance
the Commission was charged initially
from outside of the United says they're
like you
worried about violence against
Christians so they were like no no we're
worried about violence against everybody
the riots happen in Gujarat in 2002 and
they're like you see we don't like
violence against Muslims either they
name him they've never named anyone else
and Wow
and you know there's been a lot of
religious intolerance in the world in
the last 10 years people have earned the
right to be on that list well there are
some very there should there should be
some justifiably disappointed dictators
going hey hey hey what do I have to do
exactly well you look at Maliki the
prime minister of Iraq
you know our man I mean that government
has been associated with death squads
with reprisal killings and then of
course you have Saudi Arabia Oh need i
say more
right that is that is the bet that is
the perfect thing with Saudi
righteousness and then the Saudi Arabia
let's just let that hang in the air
please well you know it has two great
it's had two great exports over the last
30 years oil and religious intolerance
you know that's right yeah it is is the
landmass landmass version of an asterisk
that country um but yeah so he has a
huge huge mandate Modi what what is he
expected to do with it all he talked
about while running and he ran one of
the most disciplined really brilliant
campaigns was just all about development
and good government development and
Google people tried to get him into the
you know the anti-muslim style for Hindu
nationalists ufff he never bet he never
went there his you know he would just
keep talking about it he said one point
I'm more interested in toilets than in
temples yeah
meaning I'm gonna build you know India
famously does not have a lot of toilets
if you and people have visited notice
that you know some of that activity
takes place outdoors and so this is a
this is it you know but but that was
really the whole message was about
development and I think if you look at
go draw his state he's been pretty good
at that Gujarat has grown faster than
China in the last ten years and this is
a state of 60 million people so it's not
trivial but I think you've hit there on
the absolute key problem with the whole
thing when you enter the toilets and
temples because there was even a cartoon
information public health information
video in India trying to teach
the importance of using toilets and it
went viral and that I thought must must
be the perfect distillation of the
potential and the challenges in India
for Modi and governing India ahead
because injuries
it currently has an economic disparity
so vast that you've got fifty percent of
people with a dangerous lack of access
to toilets and the other half watching
viral videos about that problem on their
iPads we've got it desert spectacular
wealth disparity there well and
especially especially at the top so
India has I forget it's one of the five
or six countries in the world with the
largest number of billionaires and yet
you know the per capita income in India
is I think still under two thousand and
just to remind people the United States
is more like fifty thousand so it's
still a very poor country but with a
whether the haves really in an
extraordinary that the haves in India
you know the top ten percent or five
percent live like people doing Western
Europe or and and then you have the
bottom thirty or forty percent who is
still living on essentially you know
under three or four dollars a day it's
very - huge disparity and his challenge
is going to be to try to provide the
kind of growth that China has been able
to do which required you know often very
very determined government policy which
is tough to do in a democracy but that's
the promise because you know China's
development in some way is a model for
no one because most dictatorships are
not that competent I mean you know
people often say wouldn't it be great to
be it wouldn't be great to be able to
have a Chinese salary yeah but how do
you know you're gonna get the Chinese
most people get you know Marco so Mobutu
or some crazy African guy who wants to
build a temple to himself yeah and if
you could be guaranteed that you get the
kind of Chinese style technocracy that'd
be great what India represents is a
democracy that might actually make
development work and figure out a way to
get growth so it's much more
transportable right if the Indians with
their crazy messy colorful democracy can
somehow make the right choice of choices
and get economic growth well then
Indonesia can do it and Brazil can do it
you know whereas the Chinese it's like
well yeah maybe we should get the
Chinese to run every
country that's not a really a viable
model for the world that the Chinese
might like it okay so that's not not a
viable model but that's probably where
we're headed but that's what that's what
we have everything everything about this
election was fascinating to me not not
even just the result or what that what
the projections of that result it likely
to be but the process itself was
incredible eight hundred and fourteen
million registered voters and the Indian
Election Commission mandated that there
had to be a polling station two
kilometers from every place where people
were living meaning that they were
putting they were put in polling
stations up on the side of mountains and
and the results were tabulated because
it was all done electronically faster
and more authoritative Li than the
elections here well that's me Ono
hanging Chad exactly no butterfly
ballots and in terms of fighting for
access for people it's an antithesis do
you look at the voting rights laws that
are going on here they're putting
putting politics laid on the side of
mountains in Texas they will be
proposing laws building mountains
between voters and the polls it's there
was something so inspirational about it
today that is one of the things you know
growing up in India there was so many
crazy things it was it was a crazy
socialist period when I was growing up
particularly in the seventies or
nationalizing Bank so so many things
that you you felt sad about but this was
the one piece of India that was always
so inspirational that you know these
poor illiterate people not only could
vote but wanted to vote demanded to vote
and understood the issues from their
point of view and you know did it
repeatedly and there's never been
serious violence there's never been
anyone who's contested the the results
in other words the loser has always
accepted them for a country again that's
one of the poorest countries in the
world still that is an inspiration it
really is it's so exciting to me because
the possibilities seem potentially
limitless and that by the way maybe the
British have something to do with the
tradition of parliamentary democracy yes
we did it we did it
if we take if we take nothing else away
from this evening I'll take that as a
verbal thank you that in fact it was
this we saw we did our first show we did
we did a whole big section on the Indian
idea and it went it was seen quite a lot
in India and there was a bit of pushback
in India with with people being angry
saying the map over my shoulder was
drawn wrong and to that I say I'm
British that's impossible I got that's
just the way the map is now just like I
can't get it wrong it might it was
probably the piece of Kashmiri at the
part that s contested between India and
Pakistan so when I got as a kid a my
copy of the Encyclopedia Britannica
which my parents had bought for me I
can't remember I think my 14th birthday
or something the page with the map of
India was blacked out by the Indian
censors so it's like you can't take a
look at this you know it's it's just too
horrific just see it's a I can't thank
you enough VIN it is nothing that is not
fascinating about about this whole
election and I can't think of anyone
better to talk to better than you thank
you so I really appreciate great show
you